GREG: I want to
bring up Brad Abrams.
He leads the Product Management
Team for our Developer
Experiences group,
and he's going
to give us a demo of Zero to 60
on the Cloud Platform showing
these productivity features.
Brad?
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome,
thanks, Greg.
GREG: Do you need that?
BRAD ABRAMS: No,
I don't need it.
So in his copious
spare time, Greg's
been building out this Cloud
Event 2014 application,
but he ran into a
little snag, and he
asked me to use my programming
prowess to help him out.
So what we're looking at here
is the Google Developer Console
for Greg's application.
But before we drill into
the console, how many people
are command line fans?
How many people are more
productive on the command line?
Let's hear it, OK.
GREG: Yep.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD ABRAMS: Great, yes.
Me too.
So we're going to start there.
I'm going to show you our
new gcloud command line tool.
The reason I'm more
productive on the command line
is because of keyboard
shortcuts like Tab completion.
So I can just say
"gcloud," Tab, Tab,
and that shows me
the list of options
that are available there.
And then-- if I can type--
a Tab again completes that.
Oh, yeah.
And then what were the
options for components?
I can't remember.
Oh, right.
List is the one I want.
Tab finishes that out.
So pretty cool, huh?
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Oh, fine.
All right, so we have a set of
components that are available.
I could add, remove those, but I
have what I think I need there,
so we'll clear that.
And I'll do another
gcloud command,
and we'll go ahead--
cloudevent2014-- we'll
go ahead and bring down
code that Greg's already
started onto our local
workspace so that we
can start getting
started with this.
So let's take a look at
what Greg's already got.
I'm going to use my second
favorite editor here
to check out Greg's code.
And there-- Greg, I
think I see your problem.
You forgot to give it a title.
So let's see if we can
do that, so GCP Live!!
OK, just save that.
Now, we're going to
use Git to commit that
to our local repository.
How many big Git fans
are you-- use Git?
[APPLAUSE]
Yes?
Awesome.
So I'll do a git commit,
and I'll say, add a title--
or whatever.
GREG: Or a "tite."
BRAD ABRAMS: And then I'm going
to go ahead and do a git push.
So when I did the gcloud init,
I initialized my local workspace
with the remote repository
that's hosted for us
in the Google cloud.
And now, I've gone
and pushed that up.
So if we switch over
here to the console,
you'll see-- when I refresh
this-- that our new source code
viewer in the console has
that change that we looked at.
There it is-- "GCP Live!!"
And now if I switch
over to Releases,
we see this is the
Git URL that we
offer as part of every
developer console project.
You get a free,
private Git repository
that's accessible to all the
members of your development
team on this project.
GREG: Now, that's really cool,
and a lot of people do use Git,
but a lot of people
also use GitHub--
whether it's for public
open source projects,
or even for private repos.
So is there support
for that too?
BRAD ABRAMS: Absolutely, Greg.
At Google, we are
big fans of GitHub.
And so--
GREG: How did I know that?
BRAD ABRAMS: We've gone ahead
and added a Connect a GitHub
button.
So all the features I'm
going to show you work great
if you're using a GitHub
repository or one of ours.
So regardless of which you
use, as a post-commit action,
you have your choice
as to what happens.
We can do a build,
run a set of unit test
before we deploy
that into production.
In this case, we've set
it to build with Maven,
run unit tests, and then
deploy to our cloud platform.
To give you a peek inside-- a
little bit about what's really
happening-- when we configured
that build, what we did
is we spin up a Compute Engine
instance, and we installed,
on your behalf,
Jenkins, Maven, JDK--
everything we needed
to do reliable builds.
And then when that
git push happened,
we pulled down all the
code and did a clean build.
And then when that build passed,
we ran all your unit tests
and then pushed
it to production.
So you can be more sure you get
a safe, reliable deployment.
And you can see, as I practice
this demo, the spikes in the
build machines.
So if we switch back
over to Cloud Deployment,
you can see our release history.
And what you see
here is that we added
that title, we did a build,
test, and we deployed that
into production all in the
time we've been talking here.
So if we switch over and
see Greg's app-- Greg,
it looks like a little
meme application.
That's kind of cool.
And it's going to refresh
with-- and we see these.
Here are the memes you have.
Yes.
That's cute-- petabytes of data.
And there's the
title that we added.
That's great.
I'm interested in what our top
memes are, here at the Cloud
event, so let's check those out.
Oh, Greg.
You have a server error here.
A 500 server error--
that's not good.
These kind of issues
are hard enough
to debug when it's on
your local machine,
but when you have an issue
like this in production,
it's even harder.
So to give you a sense about
debugging this in production,
I'm going to switch over and
give some simulated load--
so just going to throw a
lot of traffic at that site.
I saw some of you
copying down the URL,
so you might be throwing
some traffic at it as well.
So we'll go over and look
at how we debug that issue.
So I'm going to bring up
the new unified logs viewer,
and we're getting a log
entry for every request that
comes in.
And you saw-- I just
threw a bunch of requests
at this thing.
And we're aggregating
all those logs
across every front end
instance that were spinning up
into a single unified view.
And so now, I can just
scroll through here.
And notice, as I'm scrolling,
it's loading new logs,
so it's easy for me to find
logs that I'm interested in.
I can also filter these.
Or in this particular
case, though, I
want to look for a status
500, because that's
what we saw-- the
500 server error.
I can also come in and
filter by date and time.
So if I get a bug report
at a certain time,
I can narrow that
down pretty easily.
These filters can be chained
together with "and" and
"or" so you can get
exactly what you want.
OK, so here are the
errors that we're hitting.
And I can see, Greg,
the problem here
is in this ominously named
method-- getMemes_Buggy.
Hmm, that must be the problem.
GREG: I had to make it
easy for you to find, Brad.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes,
I appreciate that.
So speaking of
finding that, you'll
notice the next thing we
want to do, as a developer,
is jump into the
source, because that's
where we're going to be
able to fix this problem.
But I have all this
context loaded in my head.
I need to get to
the source quick
so I can start
bringing that to bear.
So what I'm going
to do is-- notice
that right here, this
is actually a hyperlink.
So if I click right
on this hyperlink,
it brings me into the console,
into our source code view,
with exactly the version
of the source code
that was deployed
into production
and that line of highlighted.
Pretty useful?
[APPLAUSE]
So at this point, we could drop
back to the Git command line.
We could pull that file down
and start operating on it.
I can click on this
Open in IDE button
and use a variety of third
party or Google provided IDEs.
Or because this is
a very quick change,
I can just click on Edit,
make this change right
in the browser, and go
ahead and do a commit.
And we'll just say "Fixed
Greg's buggy code,"
and we'll deploy
that into production.
Now, how many of you who have
been debugging a production
issue, and you've ended up
SSHing into a production
machine and twiddling
some config file
or messing with some PHP code?
Who's done that?
Yes, I-- who's done
that this morning?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, a couple of you.
And that's maybe
not the best idea,
and that is not what
we're doing here.
We're actually committing
this change back
to the production
Git repository.
That change is attributed to me.
It's repeatable.
All future deployments will
have that code as well.
And we're running that
full-release pipeline.
We're building the code
on a clean machine.
We're running all
our unit tests,
and we're deploying it only
if all those things pass.
Now, that takes a minute or
so for those things to happen,
so let's see if we can view
that deployment in progress.
So let's open that in a new tab.
And we should see
our new release.
There it is.
We fixed Greg's buggy code.
Notice, it's already
built and tested
that in just this short time,
and we've deployed that out
into production.
So if we switch over
now and refresh this,
we should see the
top Cloud memes.
And of course, they're
all Jeff Dean memes.
[LAUGHTER]
Guess that's how it goes.
So what you've seen
today is it's very easy
to use tools you already know
and love like Maven, Jenkins,
and Gradle to be able
to target our platform.
You've seen how
easy it is to get
reliable and quick deployments
with our new continuous
integration system.
And finally, you
saw how easy it was
to find and debug an
issue in production
and get that fixed quickly.
Thanks, Greg.
GREG: Thanks, Brad.
[APPLAUSE]